the lottery is obviously pretty hard to
win but of course we had to test it
ourselves so we got a few wired
colleagues to play a scratcher game I
didn't win anything I did not win
anything nothing I got nothing I lost
but I didn't nothing we have won five
dollars so I'm up by two dollars
scratchers are just one of the many
lottery games out there
beyond that you have draw games at both
the state and National level and in
particular the Powerball which keeps on
making the news because the jackpots are
so big there are definitely lotteries
that are easier to win than other
lotteries when you gamble normally a
bigger chance of winning means lower
payout so for example this is familiar
from roulette where if you bet on red or
black you get less money in return than
if you bet on a single number where you
get a lot more to return because your
odds of winning with red or black bet is
much higher similarly your odds of
winning on a Powerball or Mega Millions
ticket are very low about one in 300
million let's look at that one more time
your chances of winning the Powerball
jackpot equal about 1 in 300 million
they're all kinds of Lottery prizes out
there and some of them are still pretty
big but they're not a billion dollars
next play in certain numbers you're not
going to increase your chances of
winning by some strategy about out how
you pick the exact numbers that you pick
however for games like Powerball and
Mega Millions what you'd like to do if
you win the jackpot is to be the only
one who wins the jackpot so you don't
split it so with that perspective in
mind you'd like to pick unpopular
numbers you'd like to pick numbers that
other people will pick don't pick dates
for example because a lot of people
gamble based on dates other advice might
be if you look at the ticket where you
pick your numbers don't just pick a
column of numbers on that ticket for
example because some people will do that
repeat winners Like Richard lusting won
over one million dollars advocated for
playing sequential numbers now this
won't increase your odds of winning that
kind of thing is going to give you the
same chance of winning as the jackpot as
any other method of choosing however
if you look at a ticket like that it
looks weird so many sequential numbers
help you
not share the jackpot which is good I
don't know but that's how it strikes me
as a mathematician so what are some ways
that people attempt to crease their odds
of winning the lottery first playing
every single number combination in the
drawing so for Mega Millions and
Powerball that's not really a feasible
choice because there's 300 million
tickets it's super hard to go to the
store and buy that many tickets you need
a whole Army of helpers it's a
complicated Endeavor but for smaller
state level lotteries which have fewer
tickets that you have to buy and also a
smaller jackpot people have done that so
in particular in New South Wales in 1986
a Syndicate did that in Virginia in 1992
and then of the Irish National Lottery
now in these cases they didn't actually
succeed in getting 100 of the tickets
but they got enough that they got lucky
and they did win the jackpot now if you
do actually decide to do this there are
a bit of logistics involved you're
actually going to have to go to the
stores and buy those tickets you can't
just pay the clerk in a lottery store to
buy those tickets because they're not
allowed to do that by most lottery
regulations and there's another gotcha
that's really obvious which is it could
happen that someone else also wins the
jackpot and you have to split it with
them so as someone trying to pursue this
strategy you absolutely want to keep
your eyes open to that possibility
finally some states have a higher chance
of winning than others statisticians and
economists have mapped out states that
have a high rate of return a good recipe
to look for is you want a lottery where
maybe not a lot of people are buying
tickets and yet the jackpot is pretty
big so there's a classic example of
Oregon 1999 they had a 18 million dollar
jackpot and yet they didn't sell that
many tickets and what that means is is
when you buy a ticket in such a drawing
you're unlikely to share the jackpot
similarly in the mid-auts in Texas the
Llano Texas had drawings like that as
well and so looking around for those
kinds of drawings that's one way to
increase your expected return on buying
a lottery ticket and scratchers can High
rate of return
is Lottery has
printed them out and picked the prizes
in such a way that the total value of
the prizes is less than the amount
people are going to spend on tickets so
they're going to make money on average
you buy scratcher tickets and you're
gonna lose money just like any other
gambling that said
sometimes it happens that the big prizes
in the scratcher game don't get bought
at the beginning of the game and so
effectively all the people buying up
those tickets at the beginning got
unlucky and they didn't get the big
prizes and then the remaining lottery
tickets the remaining scratchers that
wait to be bought have too many prizes
many states show you how many of the
prizes have been claimed and that
information gets aggregated into other
websites like scratchoffods.com and
similar sites where you can go to that
site and they'll tell you sort of which
lottery scratcher ticket games have
better payouts right now okay
even if you've
watched higher video it'll think I need
to win a lottery is there a way you can
actually guarantee a lottery win you
find a game where you have to guess a
four digit number and you bet the
six-way box that means you're gonna bet
on a four digit number with repeated
digits like one one two two or one two
one two and if you bet a six-way box if
that's all the possible six possible
ways of writing a number with oh two
ones in it and two twos in it and if you
do that your odds of winning are one in
one thousand six hundred and sixty seven
and in Most states if you hit that if
you win that bet you will get eight
hundred dollars which means you got to
go to a lottery office you probably owns
money just so you know it is not a
recipe for making money but it is a
recipe for getting to that lottery
office with the least amount of effort
and there even used to be a game where
you're almost guaranteed to win Marge
and Jerry Selby ended up winning almost
8 million dollars playing the
Massachusetts cash win fall they even
made a movie about it we are betting
forty thousand
you guys drug dealers no for
professional Lottery players in cash
windfall the way it worked was when the
jackpot gotten pretty big they would
take some of that money and increase the
value of the smaller prizes so to win
the jackpot you have to pick the right
number it's about a one in nine million
chance but the smaller prizes are much
more likely to win so if you could buy
some but not all of the tickets in that
situation like say you could buy a
million tickets your odds of winning the
jackpot are not so big one and nine but
you're gonna win a bunch of the lower
tier prizes which are now bigger and if
they're enough bigger you're going to
make money out of your total investment
it's really hard and unusual to be in a
situation where you can reasonably
expect to make money on the lottery it's
gambling you might get lucky but it's
really getting lucky but I'm not telling
you don't buy lottery tickets I
personally buy lottery tickets I buy
them for the fantasy to think for a few
days about oh what happens if I win this
big jackpot and that's really worth
something
foreign